it's great to be joined today by Ryan
Nicodemus who is one half of the duo the
minimalists with his best friend Joshua
fields Milburn they are both the
subjects of a recently on Netflix
documentary called
the minimalists let's first explain to
people for whom this idea might be a new
many people might be familiar with the
interior design concept of minimalism
but you you guys are going well beyond
that aren't you yes yes yeah I mean if
you were to look up the definition you
know Webster's dictionary of minimalism
you probably would come back with some
art or architecture type definition for
Josh and I you know we look at
minimalism as this thing that helps us
to get past things to help us make room
for life's most important things which
you know it turns out aren't things at
all really minimalism is is living
deliberately it's it's living with
intention and not just you know kind of
acting on those impulses that we have
every single day because certainly those
are you know influenced by so many
different factors around us the
documentary is super interesting and I
hope people will check it out on Netflix
or wherever it's really available
elsewhere as well you see in the
documentary that some of this has to do
with stuff and items and sort of
decluttering it also has a lot to do
with relationships it also has to do
with sort of your relationship to not
only other people but also to sort of
our planet and the world talk to us a
little bit about how or at what point
you became sort of enlightened or maybe
motivated to seek the change that you
made well you know it's funny when I was
18 years old I remember sitting with my
best friend Josh Milburn at the senior
lunch table together and you know we
were talking about what are we gonna do
when we graduate how are we going to to
live our lives and I just remember
looking at Josh and saying hey man if we
can just make $50,000 a year you know if
we can figure out how to do that I'm
pretty sure that that will will make us
happy and in the
the place I got that thought from was
working for my dad painting and hanging
wallpaper he's got it you know just
small business in Dayton Ohio and I used
to work with him during the summers and
I just remember you know always working
in really really nice homes like stuck
with like bowling alleys and endure like
carpeted garage like just unbelievable
10,000 square foot carpeted garages that
are just like just you know something I
never really aspired to have but I
remember working in like a home which I
thought was something that maybe I could
aspire one day was it was nicer than
anything my mom or dad at ever owned and
you know I look at my dad I'm like man I
was like this house is really nice how
much how much do I have to make to own a
house like this it my dad's like well if
you can make fifty thousand dollars a
year you can probably have a house like
this so that's kind of like where where
I started and I'll tell you after high
school Josh and I both got sales jobs we
were working for the same
telecommunications company and we
started making 50 grand pretty quickly
and we realized you know we had made a
really really bad mistake you see we had
forgot to adjust for inflation so we
thought okay maybe $65,000 a year maybe
$90,000 a year and you know by the time
I was 28 years old you know I had
everything I ever wanted I had
everything I was supposed to have I had
an important job title with the very
respectable corporation I had a you know
2,000 square foot condo three bedrooms
two bathrooms two living rooms I have no
idea why me as a single guy would ever
use two living rooms but you know maybe
you kissed one caught fire ID I needed
an extra um but but you know there I was
kind of surrounded by all of this stuff
and if you weren't if you were to have
leg went back in time and told my 18
year old self hey Ryan you're not you're
not gonna believe all this stuff that
you have when you're 28 years old you're
gonna have you know a huge condo you're
gonna have all the stuff to fill it
you're gonna be able to you know buy a
nice new fancy car every couple years
you're gonna be making well over six
figures like you're gonna you're gonna
have have all of that I would have been
the most excited 18 year old ever but
you know when I turned 28 years
there I was with everything I was
supposed to have but I felt the exact
opposite I felt a lot of discontent I I
was I was depressed and I really didn't
understand why and the more I started to
think about it the more I realized I
have been you know kind of chasing the
American dream
and it just wasn't my dream and I didn't
really know how to how to approach life
after I kind of was you know going
through this and I noticed my best
friend Josh he had over the last six
seven months had really changed his
attitude changed what he was focusing on
and and you know I thought because just
to preface it a little bit I thought
because you know his mom and his mom had
passed away and his his marriage ended
both in the same month I thought maybe
like the doctor had put him on some like
Prozac or something because his attitude
had changed so much and I sat him down
eventually and I'm like dude what is
going on with you man like we're working
at the same corporation we both have you
know the same crappy boss and you seem
like legitimately happy like what are
you doing differently than I am and that
is when he introduced me to this thing
called minimalism and he told me about
how he was taking the last several
months simplifying his life getting the
clutter out of the way to make room for
what was most important to him and then
he introduced me to an entire community
of people who were doing the same thing
he introduced me to a guy named Colin
right he was a 24 year old entrepreneur
who you know traveled to new country
every four months carrying with him
everything he owned on his on his back
not anything that I wanted to aspire to
be but I really respected this
gentleman's level of commitment to
living deliberately so he could be this
peripatetic writer and then he
introduced me to other folks like Joshua
Becker who was a 36 year old husband and
father who had a full-time job in a car
and the house and the suburbs then there
was a gal named Courtney Carver she was
a 38 year old wife and mother to a
teenage daughter in Salt Lake City
and then there was this other guy named
Leo bouta he was a 38 year old husband
and father of six living in San
Francisco and you know while all of
these people were living considerably
different lives people from different
backgrounds and different you know
socio-economic situations I noticed that
they all shared at least two things in
common and the first was they were all
living deliberate meaningful lives they
were passionate Purpose Driven they
seemed much richer than any of the
so-called rich guys I worked with in the
corporate world and second they
attributed their meaningful lives to
this thing called minimalism so me being
the problem-solving guy that I am I was
like great like this this looks like
something I could totally adopt again I
didn't want to live any one of their
lives right um but I thought it I
thought adopting this this this ideology
of simplicity would help me at least
filter through all the crap in my life
so you know I looked at Josh I'm like
dude this sounds awesome
I want to be a minimalist now now what
do I do I sort of wanted to go next I
mean for people for whom this seems
appealing at least in concept right
what's the simple first step that people
can sort of do to dip their toes into
this pond and start to feel it out yeah
so for me when I looked at Josh I'm like
what do I do now we came up with this
crazy idea called a packing party where
we decided to pack all of my stuff up as
if I were moving and then I would unpack
things as I needed it day by day so like
Josh came over and literally helping me
pack up everything my cups and plates
and bowls and we covered up my furniture
you know disconnect the Wi-Fi put that
in a box
my TV my clothes my toiletries
everything and after three weeks it was
I mean it was a really cool experiment
for me being a single guy who didn't
have any kids I thought that was a great
great first step especially for me as
someone who always in order to make a
lasting change I really have to change
my state and
was a great way for me to change my
state now that might be a first step
that's a little bit too radical for
other people so I kind of I like to
think of it as like there's this you
know one side of the spectrum where you
certainly could have a packing party
pack everything up unpack it as you need
it
for a family like Leo's of a family of
six I don't think that that's probably a
reasonable expectation for the whole
family to jump on board well then
there's the other side of the spectrum
where you can you know people can do
with what Josh did just committing -
well first off people have to need to
declutter right like I don't want to
just propagate someone renting a
dumpster and throwing away stuff that's
that could certainly leave someone
miserable and in an empty apartment to
sulk yeah um but you know if someone
asks that question how am I my how might
my life be different if I own less and
they could see the benefits behind that
then they can start really small and do
what Josh did by you know getting rid of
he started with one item a day for 30
days and of course after 30 days he got
rid of way more than 30 items because
you know once he wants to go get rid of
one dvd he's like wait a minute
there's like you know 20 DVDs here that
I could probably get rid of and as he
was kind of asking himself that question
every day okay what is one thing that I
can get out of my clutter or you know
get out of this hoard it turned into
much much more and then you know so
that's one that's the other side of the
spectrum then I think there's a middle
road and this is this is something that
tens of thousands of our readers have
tried and I've seen a lot of good
results with it I'm Josh and I came up
with this thing called the 30-day
minimalism game where essentially you
find someone else who wants the
declutter so you know we know
decluttering can be pretty boring but if
you find someone to like play along with
you it's it's not so bad so you know you
get a co-worker friend family member and
you both start this on the first day of
any month so any any month it doesn't
matter which month but start on the
first day and you each get rid of you
agree to get rid of one item apiece and
then on the second day you get rid of
two items of piece and then the third
day
three out of the piece on the fourth day
you get it so forth and so on yeah so
it's really easy in the beginning man
like you know day ten day 12 but then
you get to like day 20 and then you know
day 21 and then I'm crap I gotta get rid
of 22 things the next day so it gets
harder and harder as time goes on so
basically the way the game works is
whoever lasts the longest wins if both
people make it through the whole month
awesome because then both people would
have gotten rid of about 500 items in
that case they both win but yeah it's
it's uh there's definitely several
different ways to start and you know it
depends on on where the spectrum you
fall in and how many people you have in
your household but I think there's a
couple ways that that should help people
to get get this thing rolling well one
of the main criticisms that there is
when you read online about minimalism
and there's so much positive written
about it and you've talked a lot about
it and I think many in our audience will
sort of immediately see the positives
one of the criticisms is that minimalism
is something that the privileged wealthy
can do in other words you can afford to
get rid of stuff that when you think
about it did I use this in the last
month know that I use it in the last two
months know that I use it in the last
six months know stuff that you might
only use once a year it's way more
affordable for someone who can just get
rid of it and buy it the next time they
need it and that by it's sort of
inherent nature that this is a movement
that doesn't work for the lower middle
class poor people etc what's your
reaction to that yeah I mean if you take
someone's situation who is you know
making oh let's just I don't know where
the poverty line is I think it's around
eighteen thousand bucks it's called
let's go actually let's go with the
homeless guy $0 okay and if you give
that man ten thousand twenty thousand
dollars there is research that shows
that yes there is an amount of money and
there an amount of things that can
certainly increase this this man's level
of happiness and just you know not just
that but well-being right but that goes
only to a certain point in our
documentary I think it talks about how
you know that point is like you know
50,000 or 60,000 dollars a year which
there's a you know there's a couple
things in the documentary that
I don't necessarily agree with but there
are studies that show that so that's you
know that's a stat in there but my point
is is that I don't think that there's
anyone on this planet who would not
benefit more from living deliberately
because yes there are certainly money
and there are physical possessions that
that we have as resources but then there
are also resources like time and
attention that I would argue ours are
the two most valuable resources but you
know it doesn't really matter what what
my opinion is you know the the the
Bureau of Labor Statistics shows that
now you know poor people have the same
access to luxury goods as rich people
TVs computers cell phones so forth and
so on
so you know there are certainly there
are certainly uh physical items out
there that poor people can find
themselves getting trapped in to your
point though cuz I cuz I don't want to I
don't want people listening to this
think that we're just propagating people
throw stuff away
right um first uh first and foremost we
propagate that if you have a hoard of
things if it's not adding value to your
life then we really strongly promote
finding another home for those items
donating contributing contribution
tribution to your community with those
items can certainly help you know people
who are who are less fortunate but you
know at the end of the day there is a
rule that Josh and I tend to follow when
it comes to these you know just in case
items and it's we call it the 2020 rule
and you know basically the rule we our
theory is is that this works 99% of the
time I'm sure there's an exception to
this rule but typically if there's an
item that I absolutely need I can get
that you know absolutely necessary item
in less than 20 minutes for less than
$20 and this works and in the majority
of the of the developed world and
certainly on the surface that that rule
sounds like oh well I'll just throw out
this just in case item and then yeah
I will you know go repurchase it if I
need it again and and I guess that is
kind of the idea behind it but here's
the thing is that you know Josh and I
after doing this for six years I can
count on one hand how many times both of
us have used that that 20/20 rule so I
think taken to its terminus like yeah
this is you know it could certainly be a
very wasteful money you know items out
and then items back into money out I
think that in an extreme example that
may be you know I see I see where that
that attitude is coming from but at the
end of the day though that's not if
you're if you're decluttering
deliberately then you're not bringing a
bunch of stuff back in you you are you
are getting rid of the superfluous
things now is there someone you know out
in the country like I live in Montana
and in Missoula and like you know this
is one of the big cities like 68,000
people here but there are there are
certainly there are certainly cities
outside of here with you know 100 or 200
people in there and yeah like a farmer's
gonna have to hold on to some extra
bolts and maybe they've got you know a
tractor that they use for spare parts
and they're actually using that again
we're not propagating people just throw
out everything what we're saying is is
that you know look look at your
surroundings if it is stressing you out
there there is a way out if there's
clutter around you there is a way out
and not just that but the the decisions
we make every day to bring in things
into our lives whether it's physical
possessions or whether it is a
relationship whatever it may be
to do that more deliberately instead of
oh well you know I've got this actually
I got this bonus check and I could put a
down payment on this new car that looked
really cool with the bow wrapped around
it in the in the driveway for you know
that that husband got that wife is a
gift I'm gonna do that for my wife and
then going into debt I mean those are
that's a bad example of what to do with
our resources yeah um but I'd like to
think that minimalism helps people kind
of find that balance of especially you
know for poor people who have to be even
more deliberate with their resources to
help them kind of decide what is going
to add value one isn't going to add
value but yeah man certainly everyone
different circumstances everyone has
different you know socioeconomic
backgrounds and in current situations
but you know living deliberately living
intentionally I would you know I would
hate to discriminate against poor people
and say that that they aren't able to
live or they aren't able to see benefits
from living intentionally or living
deliberately I would I'd say that they
have just as much of an ability to have
positive effects from that than someone
who's rich
the documentary again is the minimalist
we've been speaking with one of the film
subjects Ryan Nicodemus super
interesting thanks so much for talking
to me today and will absolutely continue
to recommend the documentary to people
awesome and thanks for having me on the
show